offices around America hit a new vacancy
record according to Wall Street Journal
and this number is not a number that's
uh something to be bragging about here
we go uh office vacancies in major US
cities have surged to record high with
19.6% of office space Unleashed in the
fourth quarter up from 18.8 from
previous year this marks the highest
vacancy rate since
1979 wow ACC that's 44 years ago 40 yeah
44 years ago 45 years ago according to
Moody's Analytics the overbuilding trend
in the 80s and the early 90s resulted in
a glut of Office Buildings many of which
were constructed in the 50s and the 80
50s through the 80s currently the three
major US cities with the highest vacancy
rate are Houston Dallas Austin this is
all Texas by the way Texas shifting work
habits include including the move
towards working uh uh open floor plans
and remote work have contributed to the
rise in office vacan vacancies the
covid-19 pandemic accelerated the shift
leading companies to realize they need
less space per employee Tom wow wow wow
wow wow wow look at this well first of
all 19.6 is a national average um and so
you need to step back from that like
here in Miami I think the office vacancy
rate in Miami is under 6% right now um
it's very low a lot of companies and
people have moved down here so if you're
in commercial real estate Miami You'
probably the issue you got is probably
finding homes for your clients um Texas
the issue I know for fact is
overbuilding they didn't think they were
overbuilding because no private Equity
company or a large Community Bank is
going to say okay here's a billion
dollars to build this massive office
parking garage and everything goes with
it and have no one there they just got
caught out by the amount of inventory
they built which means if you're
thinking of moving to Texas where
there's no state income tax and there's
a lot other uh lifestyle things guess
what you probably get a very
costeffective um you know uh building
for your for your team there but the
other side of it is San Francisco which
is horribly vacant so when you see these
uh averages folks always remember these
are National averages and what is the
reality is the that for you as a
business is whatever the reality is in
the town where you are or you're trying
to do it and San Francisco everything's
vacant Miami everything's full and
here's a question Tom beautiful new
buildings in Texas if you're moving
there here's a question um is this is
this a permanent thing is this a
seasonal thing is this something that's
going to change what will change it are
we at a point where you know a lot of
these guys are starting to realize look
maybe the real answer is the following
Tom
20% of America is overbuilt with Office
Buildings for current population size
that we have is that the right way of
looking at it meaning at 350 million
people in America 20% of office
buildings are too much uh one too many
which means the next time we're going to
need this much office space maybe we'll
be when that 350 becomes 420 so Rob can
you see if there's a mat to say when
will US population hit 420 million but
the opposite argument to that may be by
the time we get to 420 million we're
going to have such great technology and
AI that that 20% may go to 30% may go to
40% what do you think is going to be
happening so I think they've built the
wrong the wrong stuff right now we've
got too much commercial space on a
national basis and especially in Texas
and we don't have enough like apartments
condos and things corre that people
could rent and so I look at it and the
question I ask and I'm not going to plug
anybody but there are Venture
capitalists out there and there are
startups out there that are converting
two and three floors at a time of an
office building into basically Studio
Plus Apartments uh they they get a
bathroom in there they get a kitchenet
in there and suddenly for 1,500 bucks
you know a person with a job downtown
you know has everything they need so a
lot of that space needs to be repurposed
and the Venture Capital Community and a
lot of startups are out there saying hey
give me three floors of this building I
will you lease it to me I will convert
it to you know 20 efficiency apartments
uh per floor and they're really nice
Apartments I I toured one I didn't
invest but I uh got involved and I uh uh
with a startup that's in the Dallas area
and they pulled it off and they got
three floors of an office building down
there that is now like 60 Apartments
very interesting so office and apartment
combined I mean they got some of the uh
buildings here like we were we were
going to buy those buildings on the
water on the inter Coastal remember what
they told us they said some 60% has to
be office 40% has to be tenants exactly
right yeah it's similar now not
everybody stays at the Four Season but
if you've ever driven by or seen some of
the Four Seasons a lot of times in major
cities the top five floor of the Four
Season seasons are residences and it'll
say that that's the Four Season
residences up here or Mandarin
residences that is an example of the
hotel people half of it hotel and then
half of it and then one third of to me
2/3 is hotel and one/ third is permanent
so pbd you asked the question is this
just seasonal is this sort of temporary
let me tell you something uh this ain't
going this ain't changing the game has
changed dramatically what do I mean well
just like uber did to the car industry
just like airb airb andb did to the
hotel industry just like Bitcoin did to
just normal Financial products and
fungible tokens and all that fun stuff
just like podcast did to Media same
thing's going on here with commercial
real estate Tom hit the nail on the head
damn right did you know it but I hit it
we supply and demand we've got too much
office space and not enough homes so
what do we mean we all see what happened
during Co we started using using
acronyms like WFA work from anywhere WF
work from home Co basically was the
Catalyst to what was already going to
happen people were already working
remote these things were already
occurring and then boom covid Zoom
meetings just smack you right in the
face next thing you know you're working
you got your you know your mullet outfit
going on you got you know business up
top Party Down Below you in your boxer
briefs downstairs and if you're tubing
you're masturbating ex all that Fu goad
go ahead but you know what's happening
and Tom sort of alluded to it you're
going to have these basically work where
you live type buildings where people are
having a less kids we know that uh you
don't need to be running around to the
office anymore you know there's this
hybrid work things we obviously know
that you're a big advocate of getting
your ass in the office so am I but most
companies are totally cool with you
working remote especially if you can
find the best talent but it comes down
to supply and demand there's not enough
uh homes out there people want to work
from home there's way too much
commercial uh office space so rents are
going to be a little bit lowered and
that's going to be good for a little
company based in Fort lauderale called
value tainment cuz we're looking for a
hom office campus and some of these guys
that are looking to sell their property
are going to need to basically off
they're aggressively aggressively
recruiting us to move to Miami so we're
going to see what's going to happen with
if that sounds horrible Pat we don't
want to be living in Miami not what we
need aggressively recruit us to move the
building to Miami but do you want to
make sense of this pad on your end yeah
I I I think that's the I'm purely asking
data like when you pulled up the
population not going to get to 370
million people but God knows when you
know like 366 most likely by 2100 that's
what 76 years from now to get to 360
where are we right now Rob 335 340 I
mean population yeah what's the US
population right now so we going to go
uh uh okay 331 that's but that's 2021 so
let's just say 2024 we're at 340 give or
take I don't know I I I don't know if
this yeah 335 in the US I don't know if
this applies to all Industries I don't
know if this applies to Industries I
think it's going to be pocket I think
it's going to be cities I think it's
going to be regulation I think it's
going to be overb Buu I think it's going
to be a lot of that stuff and by the way
you know Black Rock right now is laying
off 3% of their employees that's 600
employees that be laying off even though
their numbers are back up they're doing
okay but you know it it's going to it's
going to be predicated based on Tom go
ahead you're you're trying to say
something he's itch I know it when he's
moving I was I was waiting for you
because those three lines over there on
the left are pretty interesting got it
so so one birth every 9 seconds one
death every 9 seconds and one
interational migrant every 28 seconds
then a question you have to ask on top
of all this is where does AI fit into
all this that's the part where does Ubi
fit into this Universal basic what's
going to happen with all that stuff yeah
so again we'll see what's going to
happen there so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here
n